I'm going to get so crazy at the Holiday
office party tonight I am going to go
insane at the Holiday office I'm going
to be like I'm going to be
like you sure that's a good idea our
bosses are going to be there do you want
to get
[Music]
fired the China to shop cuz I'm bullish
at the party ain't trying to stop it's
that time of year for the holiday office
packing U TI LS and egg knard dry clean
soups plus a holiday tie I'm dressed to
kill I hope you're ready to die at the
office part anything goes honey hiny can
required optional clothes had a spars
black on the cab ride over so I'm sloppy
and ho just like a boozed up go going to
drain the open bar those light Crush
yellow tell like Taliban Crush gu might
have seven boxes and four name Paul but
they can suck on my memos cuz tonight
I'm been a b cuz it's the office
punction we end up the punch sing and
now we got theun to we got
a
[Music]
everybody take my coat so I can peacock
my sweater I'm killing cheese Cub y'all
better restock the cheddar Devil's on
Horseback that's a prune inside a bacon
shoveling surfing Turf while I'm Harlem
shaking better spread than Playboy I'm
crushing these sliders like my canth co
reaction dress shoes Crush spiders
chocolate fountain fruit on a stick
ladies go crazy
for dud with pumping black ey PE I'm
grinding in my chinos call me sideways
way I'm sucking down the p no more flues
we get in I'm a nasty bird you be my
sweet honey up Single Ladies that's all
it sing ladies how about you make some
mistakes remember the magic moment we
had on the elevator hey how's it going
good see you later middle name is
unwanted Advan publicly displaying I'm
your
[Music]
private of the F second or now we got
the I'm so everybody to I'm drunk around
my boss let's drunk around a boss let's
drunk around his boss we all Heavy song
that's hit Chief and iTunes gift card I
don't feel specially gift card hey Devon
you're the only black eyy on the floor I
just think that's cool we should hang
out more I'm probably going to quit and
go to be school I'm better than this
place I'm better than all of you
everyone here has the IQ of a fluke and
I'm the fisherman the fisherman I what
to do let's play not that kind of
party you Marty let's start the grind
train start all
AB naked
[Music]
twister now we
got
we
[Music]
got I don't think they needed to fire us
you urinated in their oven that's why
they call it a
party